Thomas where is the hummus gotta have a
trim good suit my one big concern today
with the zoo is it's been so used to
cooking these little oh it's a
completely different set today I hope
didn't get the better room he just stays
focus there you little bit lost in the
kitchen with all the space are we happy
with some if I'm gonna be fine
exit Chris is cooking a traditional
spicy lamb tagine
so with couscous but he's not stopping
there I also cook a stunning lamb dish
I'm gone that extra mile and make him
bread right the authentic semolina bread
will be served with fresh hummus a
unique spice mixture of tomatoes roasted
peppers chillies and coriander took up a
table for always ooh lamb tagine yes sir
Momo for stunning lamb yes chef thank
you
debut Tamamo is preparing a delicious
roast loin of lamb with aubergine ragout
barley couscous and a lamb's liver with
harissa wrapped in spinach and
deep-fried in tempura batter I want to
do something else in North African
Student I want to show the next level
the next dimension we can go love's of a
tempura and you're wrapping the liver
yes your spinach
deep-fry hopefully just about 50 51
seconds yeah but and get last time twice
so you all really are pushing about in a
big way that's incredible it's pushing
the boundary out with the Lambs liver
which is not everyone's cup of tea
I just hope an hour's time that doesn't
go back to buy him on the ass give me an
estimated time for 45 minutes max chef
if there's ever a night to work as a
team this is it but as the pressure
builds Chris is up to his old tricks
look just make it ready for me I'll show
you first no Evan he's such a control
freak wait wait I check it can't stop
and he can't help themselves he wants to
do everything
no no no you go touch the plate yep
okay as whose first dishes hit the pass
within minutes
Jesus God that was quick okay so this
please
first table coming out Rob let's go Izu
yeah Cheryl covers Table six Mass Chris
yes chef
it's dinner yeah take your time yes I'd
pull down chef's service please
let's go Chris is cooking faster than
[ __ ] Usain Bolt runs he's just
totally focused refuses to talk to me
and he's had this steep writing that
couscous I'm fourth buzzy and here we
are
thank you let's go
amazing really the bread is bread is a
grandmother my grandmother
that's happening she's too many I'm very
proud to be this us was too much sauce
for me ready for my test yeah yeah yeah